[Musik]
einen guten abend 22 uhr 13 haben wir
ist donnerstagabend sie sind es wir sind
es auch hier sind die gäste dieser
sendung und das ist unser thema die
hälfte aller europäer könnte sich in
zwei monaten anstecken das sagt die whu
omikron wird fast jeden finden heißt es
heute aus den usa geimpfte müssen
weniger angst haben natürlich aber auch
sie können sich infizieren
die virusvariante breitet sich
schnellstmöglich aus auch in ländern mit
hoher impfquote was heißt das alles für
deutschland ist omikron unaufhaltsam
oder kann man etwas mehr infektionen
sogar zu lassen weil weniger menschen
schwer erkranken welle oder wände endet
omikron die korona politik das fragen
wir uns und diese gäste
manuela schwesig die
spd-ministerpräsidentin sagt wir hoffen
das beste und bereiten uns auf das
schlimmste vor
ranga yogeshwar der
wissenschaftsjournalist weiß wären alle
gemustert würden wir nicht über omikron
reden
melanie bringt man die virologin
kritisiert bei den zahlen waren wir
zuletzt im blindflug
klaus holetschek
der bayerische gesundheitsminister
fordert eine allgemeine impfpflicht
und eva quadbeck die journalistin sagt
dagegen die allgemeine impfpflicht wird
nicht kommen
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
die begrüßt die gäste dieser sendung
ausgesprochen herzlich willkommen liebe
zuschauer breitet sich rasant in europa
aus in manchen ländern vielen ländern um
uns herum sogar sechsstellig und jedes
land scheint anders damit umzugehen
in spanien will die regierung trotz
hoher instanzen infektionen bald nicht
mehr nachverfolgen und corona dann wie
eine grippe behandeln
auch in london breitet sich omikron
rasend aus doch die britische regierung
arbeitet bereits an einer leben mit
kowitz strategie dem ende aller corona
maßnahmen eine wette auf die
herdenimmunität
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach nennt das eine untätig wurde
eine solche strategie wie in england die
auf einer durchseuchung genaues oft ohne
dass man es so nennen will was also eine
solche strategie würde ich uns niemals
empfehlen doch auch hierzulande melden
sich plötzlich and warnende stimmen
christian drosten sagt er jetzt zur
lockerung der quarantäne wir reißen das
tor ja nicht komplett auf aber wir
müssen an einigen stellen diese tür
jetzt ein bisschen weiter öffnen für das
virus und können und dürfen das auch
weil diese erkrankung in einer geimpften
bevölkerung doch nicht mehr die
krankheit schwerer hat und auch aus
bayern ungewohnte töne
omikron ist nicht älter ist eine andere
herausforderung deswegen bleibt bayern
weiter im team vorsicht aber auch im
team augenmaß
vorsicht ja aber keine hysterie und auch
keine panik
und da begrüßen wir doch gleich sehr
herzlich klaus holetschek den
bayerischen staatsminister für
gesundheit und pflege heißt das ganz
korrekt keine hysterie keine panik
corona ist nicht das ende der welt und
das vom selbst ernannten
mannschaftskapitän des teams vorsichtig
erklären sie uns diese wende
ich denke vorsicht und augenmaß
schließen sich nicht aus ich glaube wir
haben bei nikon andere voraussetzungen
wir wissen eine hohe infektionsgefahr
mit aber die krankheit schwere ist
wesentlich niedriger und da müssen wir
jetzt die richtige balance finden
vorsichtig bleiben aber genau hinschauen
welche maßnahmen sind notwendig und
richtig und natürlich auch immer die
verhältnismäßigkeit abwägen zu dem was
wir tun sie scheren jetzt ausgerechnet
wieder bei einem mp kabelschloss aus
also einem beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in bezug
auf die restaurants und gaststätten
empfinden sie kneipen restaurants als so
eine art grundversorgung dies in bayern
einfach braucht oder haben sie spaß
daran jetzt wieder an der nachhaltigkeit
dieser mpk beschlüsse zu drehen da weder
noch ich denke wir haben sehr frühzeitig
konsequente maßnahmen ergriffen seit dem
november sind bars diskotheken
schankwirtschaften zu werden eine
sperrstunde wir hatten eine hotspot
strategie und ich glaube deswegen können
wir jetzt genau hinschauen wann zweig
plus notwendig ist für gastronomie und
beherbergung das tun wir ich schließe
auch nicht aus dass das kommt aber wir
nehmen uns jetzt mal die zeit des
auszubalancieren und abzuwägen und dann
werden wir die richtigen entscheidungen
treffen gut aber sie konterkarieren
einen gemeinsamen beschluss und so
richtig als opposition cdu csu noch für
die wiederbelebung dieser epidemischen
notlage kann man sich ja dann auch nicht
mehr so richtig aussprechen frage an die
journalistin in der runde eva quadbeck
stellvertretende chefredakteurin vom
redaktions netzwerk deutschland sie
leiten hier das hauptstadtbüro frage
dennoch zu den bayern wie erklären sie
sich diese lustige wende ja das ist auf
jeden fall ein stück oppositionspolitik
vor allen dingen wenn man sieht dass
herr söder ja vor einem halben jahr noch
an der seite von frau merkel
möglichst harte beschlüsse immer
versucht hat durchzufechten und ich
finde dass von den bayern auch
tatsächlich das völlig falsche signal
weil von der minister
präsidentenkonferenz ist ja das signal
ausgegangen dass man gesagt hat leute
lasst und postern und diejenigen die
gepustet sind die können eben mit zwei
geht los in gaststätten gehen und wir
haben ja dann auch im fall der fälle
eine kürzere quarantänezeit als andere
also das war eigentlich sinnvoll dass
man gesagt hat wenn omikron jetzt kommt
und wir müssen irgendwie damit umgehen
und wollen nicht in einen weiteren
lockdown dann tun wir etwas womit wir
das signal auch an die leute setzen
können es oft einen seite eine neue
einschränkung regeln für die es machte
tatsächlich sind für diejenigen die
nicht gepolstert sind aber gleichzeitig
ein anreiz setzen dass sich möglichst
viele leute boostern können und diesen
anreiz gibt es in bayern nicht mehr
haben sie vor quadbeck ein also da wir
stehen jetzt eben entweder vor dieser
micon wand oder es kommt licht am ende
des tunnels wieder aus der sicht des
bürgers der das ja nachvollziehen soll
und vor allen dingen will
suchen wir es uns am ende selbst oder
ist es klar für sie dass wir jetzt vor
einer gefährlichen situation stehen oder
von einer art in warnung stehen ja also
wenn man so weiter macht dass man
beschlüsse fasst und ist wie immer oder
diese häufig nicht schatz sie umzusetzen
damit das virus für uns diese
entscheidung treffen und nicht wir
treffen die entscheidung also was klar
ist dass wenn man das jetzt an den
zahlen sieht wir laufen gerade in
richtig große welle rhein und die
einzige erkenntnis die man aus anderen
ländern hat ist das eben gemustert
wirklich zweifach geimpft mit dem
booster obendrauf hilft diese welle
abzuschwächen und da wir ja noch nicht
ganz so weit sind wie die anderen wäre
es ja mal schlau ausnahmsweise von den
erfahrungen anderer zu lernen
er hole check wird sich auch noch
anhören auf jeden fall was die
ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
vorpommern dazu zu sagen hat frau schrie
sich ist uns ein aus schwierigen
zugeschaltet einen schönen guten abend
zu ihnen frau schließlich sie haben
schon versucht zu formulieren wie klug
sie diese entscheidung aus bayern finden
zunahmen frau illner
bayern muss das jetzt selber für sich
entscheiden aber es ist ja so wie schon
gesagt wir haben uns nur gemeinsam
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz getroffen
und gesagt wir wollen gemeinsame
beschlüsse fassen und und dann um zwei
gibt los was wir in mecklenburg
vorpommern auch schon vor dieser mpk
hatten um im frühzeitig einzugreifen
weil unser infektionsgeschehen auch sehr
hoch war und ich staune dass bayern es
macht denn vor kurzem wohnen dort ja
auch patienten ausgeflogen und mich
haben ehrlich gesagt diese bilder sehr
berührt denn dass die stationen vor ort
nicht mehr erreichen das ist ja schon
schweres zeichen und man versucht so
etwas zu verhindern auch wenn es dafür
keine garantie gibt und wir haben jetzt
eigentlich zweig plus und ganz
deutschland und ich habe mir selber die
erfahrung gemacht dass wenn nicht
überall die gleichen maßnahmen sind dann
weichen die menschen aus natürlich sind
leute aus mecklenburg vorpommern in die
diskothek nach schleswig holstein
gefahren weil sie hier geschlossen war
ich kann das auch mit blick auf junge
haare selber irgendwie auch menschlich
nachvollziehen aber für die lage ist es
nicht gut und wir haben jetzt in allen
bundesländern doch ein sehr starkes
infektionsgeschehen dass es gut wäre
wenn wir auch überall die regeln
durchziehen quarantäne wird gekürzt für
gepostete sogar ganz ausgesetzt
wenigstens ist das morgen im bundesrat
und wird mit ziemlicher sicherheit so
entschieden und dann vielleicht ab
samstag gelten steigende instanzen
versuchen wir eben auch mit 2g plus in
den griff zu bekommen ist das eine art
kapitulation vor nikon in ihren augen
frau schwesig oder ist es ein guter plan
das ist überhaupt keine kapitulation
sondern es ist ja dieser weg zwischen
einschränkungen aber auch immer schauen
wo können wir eine kleine tür öffnen so
wie es eigentlich osten gesagt hat und
zwei gibt los eigentlich nicht mehr
aufzuhalten ist die frage
omikron ist ja da nikon hat ja überall
schon übernommen und jetzt geht es ja um
zwei wesentliche punkte erstens es
werden sich viel viel mehr menschen
infizieren
und was heißt es aber für unsere
krankenhäuser einerseits soll es milder
sein also vielleicht nicht mehr dass
sich so viele anstecken aber durch die
masse werden sich eben nicht mehr so
viele schwer kranken entschuldigung aber
durch die masse der angesteckten gibt es
dann doch noch viele die schwer
erkranken und unser hauptziel der
politik war immer
in jeder legislatur mit
parteiübergreifend länder übergreifen
das gesundheitssystem darf nicht
überlassen und ich will noch mal eine
lanze brechen für alle die die nicht
schwer in corona erkranken aber schwer
an anderen erkrankungen leiden und auch
die behandlung brauchen das dürfe nicht
vergessen und wir haben durch diese
vielen infektionen nach ja die
herausforderung und das ist sehr
kritisch das erste mal ebend
vorzubereiten das durch viel quarantäne
im viel medizinisches personal ausfällt
vielleicht haben wir in anderen
sicherheitsbereichen auch kommen wir auf
jeden fall noch dazu melanie brinkmann
ist bei uns virologin stellvertretende
vorsitzende des expertenrates der
bundesregierung vom helmholtz-zentrum
sie helfen uns verbringt man ganz
zunächst den satz von christian drosten
zu erklären was meint er wenn er sagt
wir können diese tür ein bisschen öffnen
eben weil es keine so schwere
krankenhaus schwere mehr gibt in bezug
auf die infektion
ist das mist zu verstehen ist das nicht
misszuverstehen helfen sie uns was er
damit meint
also er hat damit einen guten punkt denn
was fakt ist das virus hat sich
verändert und wenn man die krankheit
schwere betrachtet muss man immer zwei
dinge betrachten einmal den
krankheitserreger wie er sich verändert
hat oder wie er sich überhaupt verhält
oder aber auch den wird also den
menschen der infiziert wird und der das
virus jahr in dem das aber es vermehrt
wird und auch weitergegeben wird und da
hat sich auch einiges geändert die
bevölkerung ist zum großen teil
immunisiert und
dass das sind das die ersten die guten
nachrichten
das problem ist aber dass die
unbekannten variante dass die impfstoffe
nicht mehr so gut wirken wie bei der
delta variante die musterung hilft noch
mal sehr aber die infektions dynamik ist
eben ja da ist die impfung im moment
egal leider tragen auch die geimpften zu
dieser dynamik bei und das ist das große
problem aber er ist immer die gute
nachricht alle die drei mal geimpft sind
haben einen sehr guten schutz also haben
ihr individuelles risiko sehr stark
reduziert das problem ist eben was wir
in deutschland haben dass wir so viele
ungeimpfte haben und man kann sich das
ganze als schere vorstellen wenn die
instanzen nach oben steigen sind wir es
gewohnt aus vorherigen wählen dass auch
die zahl der hospitalisierte patienten
auch sehr stark nach oben steigt also
die schere ist relativ geschlossen und
jetzt sind viele denn dann einem zustand
wird diese schere immer weiter aufgeht
und das heißt die instanzen gehen nach
oben aber die intensiv belegung die
kapitalisierung bleiben unten auf die
tote und das haben wir in kopplung und
das ist das ist ja gut und
das korreliert aber sehr exakt mit dem
impfstatus mittelgroße und euch länder
mit einer hohen impfquoten sehen die
schere sehr weltoffen und
länder wie deutschland haben gerade noch
einen müssen lehren und stehen vor
großen herausforderungen in spanien
werden wir schauen und werden auch
gucken worin der unterschied besteht
genau und deshalb kann man diese tür die
sich in öffnen kann sie hier ein
bisschen öffnen den anderen ländern kann
man sie weiter öffnen interessant wir
begrüßen sehr herzlich ranga yogeshwar
der uns aus frankfurt zugeschaltet ist
heute geschätzte journalistenkollege
wissenschaftsjournalist bekannt aus funk
und fernsehen sowie so ist die pandemie
am ende ranga yogeshwar oder ist unsere
geduld am ende
die geduld ist bei dem einen oder
anderen sicherlich am ende aber wir
erleben natürlich auch in den nächsten
monaten oder in diesem jahr allmählich
das ausbleichen der pandemie wie bringt
man hat eigentlich ganz schön erklärt es
geht am ende darum dass die
infektionszahlen sehr hoch sein können
aber das ist kein problem wenn viele
geimpft sind und damit kaum leute ins
krankenhaus gehen also wir haben uns in
den zwei jahren an den begriff der
inzidenz ungewohnt wenn wir uns in einem
winter angucken wie viele leute erkältet
sind rotzigen nasen haben könnte man
auch eine bunte statistik machen über
die enormen inzidenz von verknüpfungen
aber das würde uns nicht kümmern weil
wir wissen okay das ist kein großes
problem und genau auf dem weg sind wir
jetzt auch bei corona aber auch das ist
gesagt worden das hauptproblem ist hier
in deutschland haben wir immer noch zu
viele menschen die nicht geimpft sind
und bei denen sieht der verlauf anders
aus und wie das dann aussieht das kann
man sich anschauen in den usa in uk in
frankreich also diese wand die kommt das
wissen wir alle in den anderen ländern
ist sie angekommen und wir haben heute
incidents in der größenordnung von
80.000 wenn wir die sendungen
möglicherweise in drei vier wochen
machen dann werden wir über 200.000
treten dann davon gibt es eben immer
noch zu viele der nicht geimpft und dann
eben schwer kranke und in dieser
größenordnung reden wir eben auch bei
italien und bei spanien und auch bei
frankreich und gucken auch was diese
länder anders machen als wir und ob das
gut so ist offensichtlich neben da die
zahlen zu aber die strenge auch der
regierungen ab manuela schwesig sie
haben schon gesagt sie bereiten sich auf
das schlimmste vor so haben wir sie auch
zitiert in mecklenburg vorpommern und
hoffen das beste was heißt das jetzt
aber ganz konkret auch für ihre
krankenhäuser und intensivstationen
darauf machten sie gerade schon
aufmerksam halten sie die auf vorrat
frei wie in alten delta oder eben auch
alfa zeiten
wir haben ja bestimmte kapazitäten frei
geschaufelt für corona aber ich habe
schon gesagt trotzdem müssen andere
krankheiten weiter behandelt werden und
wir haben noch im land ganz schön auch
auf den intensivstationen auch noch mit
data zu tun und zum glück klingt ja die
hospitalisierung rate überall insgesamt
ab was ich meine ist auch ein zweiter
punkt wenn sich viele infizieren dann
wird es so sein dass eben auch viele in
quarantäne müssen und wenn die
sogenannte kritische infrastruktur in
quarantäne muss also viele lehrer viele
sicherheitsleute vor allem viele
vielleicht im krankenhaus aber es geht
auch um stadtwerke um stromversorgung um
unseren lebensmittelbereich das ist ja
immer noch ein bisschen mehr als nur
pflege und krankenhaus die sogenannte
kritische infrastruktur dann müssen wir
darüber nachdenken wie wir das aber
aufrechterhalten und deswegen haben wir
schon im letzten jahr einen krisenstab
eingerichtet der sich ausschließlich
darum im land kümmert dass wir alle
bereiche gebeten haben nicht nur a und b
teams zu machen sondern wirklich durch
zu rechnen was heißt das wenn ein
viertel des personals oder vielleicht
sogar die hälfte in quarantäne ist und
das ist auch der grund weswegen noch mal
mit den wissenschaftlern ausgelotet
worden ist wie viel quarantäne ist
wirklich notwendig weil das ist schon
eine große herausforderung das hatten
wir so noch nicht und darauf haben wir
uns vorbereitet und was ich mit dem satz
meine wir hoffen das beste und bereiten
uns auf das schwierigste vor ist dass
man natürlich immer irgendwie hofft dass
es milder wird als angesagt aber man
muss realistisch sich auch auf das
schwierigste vorbereiten die frage ist
seit vorgestern war schließlich ob sie
auch kommunizieren wollten uns war das
schlimmste kommunizieren wollten sie
haben von 100 intensivbetten in ihrem
land gesprochen und nicht von 600 und
sind von einem gericht aufgefordert
worden das zu korrigieren denn es gibt
insgesamt 600 intensivbetten in
mecklenburg vorpommern wollten sie da
bewusst angst machen
nein überhaupt nicht das hat auch mit
der nikon variante gar nichts zu tun
dass diese diskussion wie stellen wir
den menschen da was ist oft den
intensivstationen los gibt es schon
lange und wir haben immer der
bevölkerung gesagt dass wir im land
ungefähr über 600 intensivbetten haben
das aber und davon war corona wenn fast
100 betten voll sind 15 prozent das hört
sich für die menschen nicht viel an aber
man muss immer sagen die anderen 85
prozent brauchen wir für den herzinfarkt
den unfall die tumor op und und und das
gibt es ja weiter dass man hat ja nicht
halt gemacht und um was für die menschen
werben 100 genau um unsere menschen
besser darzustellen haben wir ihm immer
deutlich gemacht wie voll sind diese 100
betten und das gericht hat gesagt dass
ihr euch an der intensivbetten kapazität
orientiert neben der hospitalisierung
rat ist richtig darüber sind wir sehr
froh und sagt aber bitte weist alles aus
das ist für uns kein problem da steht
alles erinnert sich
es ändert sich an der lage nicht und nun
steht aber nachvollziehbar für den
mecklenburg vorpommern bürger die 15
prozent und nicht die 80 wenn nur
100 betten gerechnet würden als ausgangs
summe ob das nachvollziehbarer ist dann
mache ich ein fragezeichen denn dazu
muss kommuniziert werden das heißt nicht
dass es andere frei ist das ist ja auch
das problem bei der hospitalisierung
rates ist glaube ich habe ich auch schon
mal in ihrer sendung gesagt drei fälle
acht das hört sich alles nicht viel
anders denkt man ja mein gott da kann es
gibt noch viel mehr menschen die sonst
im krankenhaus sind aber noch mal wir
haben nicht nur corona und das ist mir
sehr wichtig weil seit zwei jahren
glaube die menschen die andere schwere
erkrankungen haben und auch die die
vielleicht nur was einfach ist und
anführungsstrichen haben eine hüft op
oder eine andere op das machen die leute
ja nicht freiwillig die haben schmerzen
ihre probleme da wird werden teilweise
dinge verschoben und bis hin dass
weniger vorsorgeuntersuchungen sind und
das ist alles nicht gesund und nicht
gesund und das ist richtig und trotzdem
haben sie vor in korrekter weise ja
darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass es immer
darum ging unser gesundheitssystem nicht
zu überlasten und in jahr eins dieser
pandemie sprachen wir ja mal von 25.000
intensivbetten insgesamt in deutschland
und krankenhäuser haben die auch
versucht zur verfügung zu stellen wir
müssen und dass es wahnsinnig wichtig in
diesem zusammenhang ich nahm das als
beispiel über die akkuratesse unserer
zahlen reden man kann ja richtige
politische entscheidungen nur fällen
wenn man zahlen nicht nur erklären kann
sondern wenn es fundierte zahlen sind
und damit eher hologic sind wir auch
wieder bei der frage an die politik in
bayern haben sie das gefühl dass sie auf
der basis von profunden zahlen agieren
oder ist unsere wissenslücke immer noch
größer als unsere im fluge
wir müssen glaube ich schon zur kenntnis
nehmen dass wir bei der datenlage immer
wieder auch auf schätzungen angewiesen
sind ob das jetzt die impfquote ist die
dann ein stück weit geschätzt wurde
wurde auch wir melde für züge haben zum
beispiel der hospitalisierung rate ist
ja auch ein thema die hospitalisierung
incidents ist eigentlich immer
unterschätzt wird dann vom rk adjustiert
und ist dann wesentlich höher das macht
tatsächlich auch es nicht leichter und
deswegen müssen wir genau hinschauen wir
hoffen auch die inzidenz aus meiner
sicht die ein wichtiger vor wahren wert
als eine wichtige in zieht in ein
wichtiger seismograph der notwendig ist
ich sehe das heute ja auch wir sind noch
knapp glaube ich in bayern hinter
mecklenburg vorpommern jetzt in der
inzidenz merken aber diese dynamik die
jetzt aufsteigt und ich würde mir schon
wünschen dass die datenlage präziser
wird das ist glaube ich schon ein ganz
wichtiges thema hängt auch mit dem thema
digitalisierung zusammen und da müssen
wir aus der pandemie auch lernen na ja
die frage ist noch mal zu stellen erst
ein eva quadbeck dann an ranga yogeshwar
warum haben wir immer noch
schwierigkeiten
zahlen zu generieren mit denen wir
arbeiten können diese unpräzisen
äußerungen über den jahreswechsel über
weihnachten gab es auch keine
politischen entscheidungen man denken
konnte das ist jetzt aber omikron ist
wichtig sollten wir vorsichtig sein wie
kann man auf der basis solcher fehlender
zahlen politische entscheidungen fällen
die leute auch nachvollziehen sollen
also das war tatsächlich bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jetzt
anfang januar besonders schwer da konnte
man dann tatsächlich nur schätzen dass
man sagte über weihnachten fehlt uns
ungefähr soviel und wahrscheinlich haben
wir eine so und so dramatische lage und
wenn man sich die zahlen heute anguckt
dann ist die lage auf jeden fall nicht
zu dramatisch eingeschätzt worden im
gegenteil ein großes problem in
deutschland ist das thema
gesundheitsämter und das ist ja
eigentlich auch schon relativ früh in
der korona pandemie erkannt worden dass
die in teilen nicht digitalisiert sind
das die viel zu wenig personal haben und
dass die ärzte die es dort gibt auch zu
schlecht bezahlt werden dann hat es hat
man gesagt da müssen was dran ändern und
dann änderte sich nichts wie das eben so
oft ist das problem ist erkannt aber die
politik in bund und ländern muss man
dann sagen ist nicht in der lage obwohl
genug geld da wäre auch leute
einzustellen das einfach in den vollzug
zu bringen und dann vielleicht noch ein
wort zu den zahlen bei den zahlen die
wir haben da ist es dann schon total
wichtig also sie ganz redlich zu
kommunizieren also das ist ja also wenn
man dann eben noch die zahl nimmt und
sie in seine interpretation rein schiebt
um eben seine politische richtung zu
unterstützen das merken die leute und
sie sind auch nicht so blöd komplex zu
denken und wenn man konnten was
komplexes gut erklärt dass dann auch zu
verstehen und sich selber ein bild von
der lage zu machen
melanie brinkmann von einem blindflug
indem wir sind in bezug auf unsere daten
lager und auf der anderen seite also
hier in berlin beispielsweise gab es bei
spezialisierung sprang plötzlich weil
man sich auf eine andere datei und
zahlen von dort beruf von 3 auf 10 was
einen riesigen unterschied macht und im
grunde sofort sämtliche roten ampeln
hier in dieser stadt machen müsste
andere fälle gibt es zu berichten auch
in bayern und nun heute endlich gab es
von baby und rk ii die bestätigung über
den impfstatus unserer its patienten das
heißt jetzt nach vier wochen wissen wir
welchen impfstatus die menschen hatten
die auf den interessen liegen und jetzt
können wir den menschen sagen zu zwei
dritteln sind die wirklich ungeimpft wie
problematisch ist diese blindflug von
dem sie sprach ja es ist tatsächlich
eine prekäre situation und das muss
dringend geändert werden und man
versucht ja seit 2003 das
gesundheitssystem
in eine elektronische form zu bringen
dass uns und das ist natürlich auch wäre
für diese pandemie unheimlich hilfreich
gewesen wenn es einfach schon existiert
hätte formen jetzt in die situation
kommt und realisiert wir haben ein
echtes problem und es ist natürlich
schwierig in einer pandemie das mal eben
schnell aufzubauen aber ich glaube die
dringlichkeit das ist jetzt geschehen
muss und zwar kurzfristig dass wir eine
elektronische patientenakte haben dass
wir daten generiert werden die ja da
liegen dass sie einfach schneller an den
ort kommen müssen wo viele auch darauf
zugreifen können und sie auch verwerten
können und dann auch wirklich weil jede
evidenzbasierte informationen an die
politik geben können dass entscheidung
gefällt werden können das muss jetzt
dringend passieren und die das bin ich
jetzt zwei jahren hier noch sitze in der
nächsten pandemie und wir da reden
wieder drüber dann weiß ich auch nicht
was ich noch sagen soll dann wäre schön
wenn sich dann etwas verändert hätte wie
er ranga yogeshwar erleben wir gerade
das muss man sich auch noch mal fragen
die einen echten anstieg oder geschieht
das was karl lauterbach schon ende
november anfang dezember sagte nämlich
dass sich die zahlen sicher
verdreifachen werden und dass wir eine
hohe dunkelziffer haben wird diese
dunkelziffer jetzt endlich hell oder
erleben wir einen echten anstieg wir
haben verschiedene sachen also das eine
ist natürlich werden wir einen echten
anstieg erleben zum zweiten erleben und
das kann jeder nachvollziehen wir dass
diese zahlen oft nachgeliefert werden
ich meine jeder kann sich mal die korona
statistiken anschauen von robert koch da
gibt es immer so am wochenende die
dellen und dann steht da die zahlen
werden nachgeliefert das ist ehrlich
gesagt absurd also seit zwei jahren sind
wir in der pandemie ich kann mich gut
erinnern die bundeskanzlerin hat vor
zwei jahren gesagt das virus hat keine
feiertage aber am sonntag sah man dass
die zahlen offensichtlich feiertage
haben das haben wir immer noch nicht
gelernt wenn wir von zahlen reden reden
wir ja nicht nur davon
ist gemeldet worden da fehlen auch
zahlen also warum braucht es so lange
bis wir wirklich transparenz haben was
zum beispiel die bettenbelegung betrifft
warum fehlen zb zahlen der modellierer
die ja natürlich auch sehr wichtig
werden wirklich zu wissen wie sieht die
wand aus im moment wird viel darüber
spekuliert aber die basis auf zb beim
expertenrat sind natürlich berechnungen
wo man sagt so das ist unsere basis
überall dort könnten wir aber wir können
uns jetzt den abend schlecht reden und
irgendwie depressiv nach hause gehen
denn das ist ein dauerthema
das habe ich oft genug besprochen auch
in so sendungen ich glaube da kommt man
irgendwo nicht weiter da muss in
deutschland irgend ein ruck durch das
land gehen aber ich weiß nicht wer und
wie der durch initiiert werden sie ja im
grunde wollte ich nur sagen wir sind bei
den zahlen noch nicht die andere länder
in europa haben wir liegen jetzt bei
einer 81 tausender incidents rang
erwähnte dass und bei den spanien den
italienern franzosen sind wir eben bei
200.000 und 300.000 man könnte sagen
dass wir mit einem blick nach spanien
oder italien quasi in unsere zukunft
schauen würden weil noch haben wir diese
wand offensichtlich nicht vor uns und um
so lohnen da kann es sein jetzt nach
paris zu schalten zu unserer kollegin
anna die unter anderem auch ein aus
spanien berichtet einen guten abend an
wir haben guten amt schaltete steht das
ist großartig nikon bericht gerade
sämtliche rekorde in frankreich ohnehin
in spanien auch aber die spanier
verhalten sich anders das haben wir hier
schon ganz kurz anklingen lassen wie
sieht das im alltag der menschen aus es
gibt diese irrsinnige inzidenz und auf
der anderen seite ist er eine regierung
sanchez die sagt wir überlegen
tatsächlich zu lockern wir glauben das
virus ist nicht mehr so gefährlich es
kann der beginn einer ebene kenn di me
sign in die wir hinein laufen
also mein eindruck ist wenn ich mir den
alltag anschaue jeder hat eigentlich an
einen positiv fall in seinem näheren
umfeld
viele sind einmal oder sogar schon zum
zweiten mal infiziert und das ist so ein
bisschen die haltung das virus trifft
mich ohnehin und ich hoffe nur dass es
nicht ausgerechnet in einer woche
passiert in der ein wichtiger termin
liegt denn dann greift natürlich die
quarantäne die gibt es in spanien ja
auch nach wie vor wenn sie jetzt auch
gerade von zehn tage auf sieben tage
reduziert würde wurde eben um diese
kritische infrastruktur die ja schon
angesprochen wurde aufrecht zu halten
damit die leute eben weiter arbeiten
gehen kann insgesamt kann man sagen die
pandemie hat so ein bisschen durch eine
sehr hohe ins quote in spanien und auch
durch die derzeit milden verläufe an
schrecken verloren aber sie beherrscht
natürlich nach wie vor den alltag wie er
das spanische gesundheitssystem diese
welle jetzt auch
da muss man ein bisschen von den
regionen von region zu region
unterscheiden es gibt regionen die haben
auch die höchste warnstufe jetzt
tatsächlich ausgerufen das bedeutet dass
die intensivstationen der krankenhäuser
voll sind wenn man nach madrid also in
die hauptstadt schaut da sind es vor
allen dingen die gesundheitszentren dass
es so eine art in hausarztpraxen die
sagen wir sind mit den ganzen tests wir
sind mit den krankschreibungen usw so
eingespannt dass wir eigentlich uns gar
nicht mehr so richtig um die versorgung
der wirklich kranken patienten kümmern
können bei spanien liegt derzeit bei 180
tausend fällen am tag da kann im grunde
auch keine nachverfolgung mehr passieren
und das gesundheitssystem ist einfach
durch die masse der fälle überlastet hat
die politik in spanien vor omikron
kapituliert oder ist sie einfach
pragmatisch in der wahrnehmung der
spanier
also bei den maßnahmen muss man auch
noch mal schauen es ist jetzt ja nicht
so dass da gar nichts passiert dass es
auch nicht die politik die alle
maßnahmen trifft sondern auch da sind
wieder die regionen zuständig also in
katalonien zb gibt es eine nächtliche
sperrstunde in madrid wiederum wird sehr
locker damit umgegangen
da gibt es so gut wie keine
restriktionen es gibt eine masken
pflicht drinnen wie auch draußen
die wird auch eingehalten und ansonsten
relativ viel darüber diskutiert ja das
ist interessant machen vielleicht
draußen kennen wir nicht
können sie mich und
das ist interessant dass man das eben
praktiziert und offensichtlich auch
durchhält vielleicht können wir noch mal
nach denen nach dieser impfquote fragen
auch ohne eine impfpflicht haben die
spanier die ja erreicht wie haben sie
sie erreicht sie hilft ja jetzt
offensichtlich eben wirklich um mit
omikron
ein wenig entspannter umzugehen
ja also bei dieser hohen in flotte
dann eigentlich mehrere faktoren
zugeführt also man muss sich nur mal vor
augen halten wie spanien den beginn der
pandemie erlebt hat also spanien wurde
aziz viel heftiger getroffen als etwa
deutschland und dieser schock diese
diese bilder von von koma patienten die
auf dem krankenhausflur starben und dann
auch dieser monatelange sehr sehr
strenge locker und das wirkt im grunde
nach in so einer situation wollten wir
eigentlich kein spanier wieder kommen
und dann würde die impfung sozusagen ein
bisschen als rettung herbei gesehnt und
eis die kampagne dann gestartet ist war
das auch sehr streng organisiert die
termine für die impfungen wurden
zentral vergeben so dass da keiner
durchs raster gefallen ist und es gibt
noch einen weiteren grund das ist
vielleicht auch ein unterschied zu
deutschland das gesundheitssystem
genießt ein sehr hohes vertrauen eben in
diesen diesen gesundheitszentren die ich
schon angesprochen habe wenn da die
ärzte sagen oder empfehlen sich impfen
zu lassen dann wird es auch gemacht und
das führt dazu dass spanien jetzt diese
impfquote von 80 prozent hat der
gesamtschau auf alle angeht danken ganz
herzlich für diese informationen aus
paris und fragen natürlich sofort nach
melanie brinkmann kann man erklären und
ist das ausreichend als erklärung dass
diese zehn prozent möglich machen dass
die spanier sich jetzt anders verhalten
dürfen und sogar überlegen dass sie mit
dem ende von omikron
corona betrachten wie eine grippe ja
also der vergleich mit der grippe den
mag ich immer noch nicht weil kurve 19
ist keine grippe es ist wirklich eine
schwere erkrankung und das ist auch
etwas was mir wichtig ist auch wenn wir
jetzt aufhören omikron verursacht milde
verläufe das wort mild das suggeriert
irgendwie etwas positives wie milde
temperaturen aber es ist immer noch ein
virus was sehr schwer krank machen kann
und wir kennen data oder haben eltern
noch nicht mal in seiner gänze
verstanden und das zwar in der
krankheitslast die es verursacht hat
doch noch mal deutlich stärker als die
omikron variante zumindest sieht es
jetzt so aus aber trotzdem wissen wir
vieles noch nicht wir wissen noch nicht
was ist mit long cobit bei der ricoh
mikron variante wie sind die kinder die
wir noch nicht impfen können also die
unter fünfjährigen wie reagieren die auf
dieses virus es gibt noch ganz ganz
viele fragezeichen
und deshalb würde ich auch diese tür von
der wir schon gesprochen habe ich zu
weit öffne wirklich sehr langsam öffnen
und gerade wir in deutschland sind
wirklich noch weit davon entfernt
im vergleich zu spanien und das ist
wirklich was ihr gerade gesagt haben
ihre korrespondenten der schon weg aber
was ist daran verwunderlich dass ärzte
einem die empfehlung geben die impfung
ist eine gute sache das ist leider in
deutschland auch und die machen das ging
das unfassbar ist ist dass es in
deutschland nicht so ist und das ist
etwas womit ich nicht gut klar komme
denn die dieses narrativ die infektion
ist etwas natürliches und was tolles und
viel besser als die impfung was da
draußen passiert bei einigen babbels das
ist einfach grundlegend falsch die natur
ist überhaupt nicht natürlich ist ja
auch wieder etwas positives natürlich
ist ja aber nein die natur ist grausam
und das haben viele anscheinend
vergessen dass wir durch impfungen viele
menschenleben gerettet haben ja also es
gibt ja im 18 jahrhundert ist jeder
zehnte brite an den pocken gestorben und
das haben wir in den griff bekommen
durch die impfung und ich umso wichtiger
ist die frage die wir in bezug auf am
nikon und die quarantäne stellen müssen
frau bringt man nur um das noch mal zu
verstehen wir verkürzen da jetzt die
quarantäne und zwar ordentlich wir sagen
bei den gebuchten sogar die müssen gar
nicht mehr in quarantäne
obwohl die ja auch noch infektiös sein
können wenn man richtig liest ist das in
ihren augen geht das zu weit was wir da
machen mit den quarantäne regeln weil
wir einfach nicht anders können
stichwort infrastruktur und wir können
nicht alle menschen zu hause halten wenn
wir sie eigentlich dringend
das ist irgendwas zweiter und neue
problem was wir haben durch die und
variante dass sie ebenso viele menschen
zur gleichen zeit infiziert und dass wir
deshalb auch unsere maßnahmen anpassen
müssen wie zum beispiel die
quarantänezeit zu reduzieren man muss
aber auch sagen die krähen die hähne
gleichgroße oder können wir uns
eigentlich nicht leisten schwierig zu
diesem zeitpunkt man muss sagen die
quarantäne kann verkürzt werden wenn man
die menschen frei testet und die
quarantäne ist eine belastung jeder der
als kontaktperson zwei wochen zu hause
sitzen durfte weiß dass es eine
belastung ist nicht nur weil ich nicht
zur arbeit gehen kann sondern auch so
und von da ist es gut dass wir uns jetzt
erlauben dass wir uns da raus testen
können das